notre dame che brucia abbiamo visto
tutti purtroppo nei giorni scorsi queste
immagini e ci siamo stati anche
inchiodati davanti alla televisione io
personalmente ho pianto e ho aspettato
di vedere se queste fiamme smettevano a
un certo punto che cos'è che ci ha
colpito veramente di questo simbolo di
questo monumento che davamo per scontato
che fosse eterno è proprio questo che
nemmeno un simbolo come notre dame può
resistere perché niente eterno con
questo non c'è bisogno di andare a
parigi purtroppo per sapere per avere
questo dolore della perdita che spesso
ci colpisce
basta ricordare i terremoti che abbiamo
avuto negli ultimi anni nel centro
italia tante persone sono state messe di
una prova ma anche tanto patrimonio
tanto patrimonio artistico e forse non
tutti sanno che il ministero per i beni
culturali è intervenuto e ha creato dei
depositi e di emergenza dei luoghi dove
le opere ferite dal sisma sono state
salvate messa in sicurezza sono degli
ospedali come questo di spoleto che si
chiama santo chiodo che servono per
recuperare con la speranza di portare di
nuovo queste opere nei luoghi di
provenienza
questo è molto importante anche se meno
conosciuto è questa responsabilità che
noi abbiamo di fronte al patrimonio
culturale è veramente grandissima
noi siamo in italia quindi l'italia
parla di cultura di natura di bellezza e
io oggi non voglio sembrare troppo cast
astrofica per cui è con questo con
questa apertura vorrei darvi finalmente
anche la bella notizia per fortuna ci
sono i musei
a cosa servono i musei i musei oltre ad
accogliere i visitatori oltre a esporre
le collezioni organizzarle le studiano
le conservano restaurano gli oggetti
a far sì che il più possibile possa
essere consegnato al futuro di tutta
questa eredità
allora io ho scelto l'esempio di verona
non solo perché la mia città che io amo
molto e la città in cui lavoro è oggi
sono direttrice dei musei civici di
verona ma perché verona uno dei più
ricchi giacimenti se ci pensate d'italia
quindi del pianeta giacimenti culturali
ed è un patrimonio culturale che non è
soltanto di chi la abita dei suoi
cittadini ma è un patrimonio
dell'umanità però non è patrimonio
unesco
sentite che bella questa definizione
patrimonio dell'umanità
vuol dire che è di tutti ma allora
verona che è una città famosissima
visitatissima è una delle mete del
turismo
ma quanto si sa veramente di questa
città
in media una città di 258 mila persone
abitanti che a una decina di musei e
monumenti civici ma altri musei anche
privati e collezioni ha una grandissima
densità di patrimonio culturale
ci sono luoghi molto famosi e qui
vediamo il bellissimo castello scaligero
che è un castello medievale che ha avuto
una eccezionale intervento di restauro
di un grandissimo architetto che nel
dopoguerra carlo scarpa ha fatto un
magistrale allestimento altro luogo
famoso e l'arena di verona dove si
tengono anche dei bellissimi spettacoli
un luogo veramente molto famoso è la
casa di giulietta la casa di giulietta
pensate che un museo sul mito della
verona medievale e sul mito di una delle
più struggenti storie d'amore che sia
state scritte ma di fronte a questo ci
sono anche dei luoghi altrettanto
interessanti e unici a verona meno
conosciuti e quindi ho scelto di
portarli tre esempi e parto da il museo
di storia naturale a palazzo pompei in
questo bellissimo esempio
dell'architettura rinascimentale
veronese di michele sanmicheli
questo museo che è un giacimento pieno
di reperti naturali di milioni di
reperti nazionali per preservare la
biodiversità e anche l'erede della
wunder kammer più antica del mondo che
cosa è la bomber cambia è una camera
delle meraviglie è un luogo per
eccellenza della fascinazione per la
scoperta degli oggetti naturali rari
curiosi strani questi luoghi nascono nel
rinascimento e a verona proprio c'è il
primo museo documentato queste camere
delle meraviglie che si chiamano anche
gabinetti delle curiosità c'era un
farmacista che aveva la sua bottega in
piazza delle erbe si chiamava francesco
calzolari vedete qui il suo museo nino
incisione del primo seicento che aveva
documentato un repertorio di oggetti
curiosi sterminato e tra questi oggetti
c'erano registrabili anti dei
meravigliosi fossili che provenivano da
bolca un giacimento qui a 60 chilometri
da verona a 800 metri d'altezza dove 50
milioni di anni fa c'era un mare
tropicale un datolo pieno di piante e di
pesci rarissimi quindi francesco
calzolari gli scavava già dal
cinquecento e questi oggetti questi
reperti sono stati poi scavati scambiati
acquistati perfino pensate trafugati da
napoleone insieme ai dipinti di mantegna
di veronese quant'altro per portarli al
louvre come in questa collezione che era
a verona tina di fossili che è stata
portata e adesso questi fossili sono in
tutti i musei d'europa del mondo però
ancora a verona si conserva il nucleo
più importante di questi tesori
secondo esempio bellissimo un museo a
cielo aperto museo lapidario maffeiano
non vi chiedo infanti conoscete questo
museo che è uno dei più vecchi d'europa
e qui proprio qui accanto ma questo
museo dovete sapere che è stato il
frutto della geniale
edizione di uno studioso che ha ri
organizzato una serie di collezioni di
reperti archeologici e di epigrafi in
particolare antiche per renderle
fruibili al pubblico per restituirle ma
anche per preservarle scipione maffei
sia si chiama così questo studioso che
peraltro raccoglieva anche fossili a
verona è in assoluto uno dei primi che
hanno capito il concetto moderno dei
musei che è quello di studiare le
collezioni conservare le collezioni e
renderle accessibili
questa la grande sfida avere questi tre
aspetti e tutti assieme
e poi abbiamo questo museo altro
elemento di unicità
pensate è un museo che si chiama degli
affreschi presso la tomba di giulietta
che è più conosciuta è un museo che
raccoglie e pensate dei dipinti levati
dai muri così ma perché elevati dai muri
perché come si sa la pittura ad affresco
estesa su degli intonaci su pareti e che
cosa succede quando questi edifici vanno
in rovina o devono essere abbattuti
palazzi per qualsiasi ragione bisogna
toglierli qui a verona abbiamo avuto un
caso un momento tragico
la piena del 1882 che ha costretto i
cittadini ad abbattere i palazzi
affacciati sul fiume per farsi ion i
nuovi argini e qui si sono messe in
salvo tante opere in questo momento ma
pensiamo a firenze nel 1966 ha la piena
dell'arno
abbiamo visto dell'immagine ancora in
televisione della gente con l'acqua fino
alla pancia che tirava fuori delle pale
d'altare e cercava di mettere in salvo
più possibile dei tesori perduti di
firenze pensate che tantissimo di quello
che è stato vittima della piena
dell'arno e ancora nei laboratori di
restauro ed è ancora in corso di
restauro
non perché non si non si lavori
abbastanza è ma perché sono migliaia
migliaia di opere e allora qui veniamo
un tema appunto
quanti oggetti quanti infinita di
oggetti specialmente in italia sono
infiniti potenzialmente pensate che la
raccolta l'accumulo materiale degli
oggetti
basta guardare a casa nostra è infinito
e quindi i nostri musei che sono molto
antiche anno miglior milioni di oggetti
allora uno dei temi su cui si discute di
più tra noi colleghi e dei musei è che
cosa fare per mettere in salvo
per chi serviranno poi questi oggetti
pensate che stanno crescendo per esempio
dei nuovi musei nel mondo e negli ultimi
anni vediamo una crescita tale per cui
in cina dal 2008 a oggi ne sono stati
creati circa 300 ogni anno e in italia
soltanto il 16 per sé per cento dei
musei è stato creato prima del 1960
pensate a quanta a verona no abbiamo
visto che c erano delle premesse nel
cinquecento c'è il primo museo del
settecento e tutti i nostri musei civici
praticamente nel primo ottocento sono
già istituiti per cui il tema è che a
verona ma come in altri luoghi ci sono
infiniti oggetti da conservare e
qualcuno dice ma riusciremo a sostenere
tutti questi nuovi musei riusciremo a
chi serviranno risponderanno veramente
alle esigenze delle comunità che li
ospitano
o come già paul valéry all'inizio del
novecento diceva ma i musei hanno un
capitale eccessivo e dunque
inutilizzabile per cui una nostra
domanda anche mia personale ogni giorno
quando vado a lavorare penso ma che cosa
servirà tutto questo come faremo a
constatarlo portando nel futuro ea chi
si arriva guardiamo il mercato dell'arte
l'antico in questo momento è in caduta
libera ma servirà interesserà ancora
qualcuno o ci sarà solo spazio per
l'arte contemporanea allora noi perché
questo l'opzione dobbiamo inventarci
allora qui el'innovazione
qui c'è un pensiero positivo costruttivo
che sta maturando molto molto
affascinante che ha già dei casi di
studio e degli esempi anche esperimenti
e che quello di rendere accessibili i
depositi non accessibili perché sapete
forse non tutti sanno che dei 55.000
musei esistenti al mondo
il 95 per cento delle collezioni è in
depositi che nessuno vede ai margini del
percorso di visita per cui provate a
immaginare la sfida oggi è questa anche
di curare questi musei unici pieni di
storia ma di riuscire a tirar fuori
anche quello che è rimasto dietro le
quinte che vediamo noi che ci lavoriamo
gli studiosi e quindi nascono questi
depositi
rivedete accessibile a tutti ce ne sono
alcuni esempi ne sta nascendo una
rotterdam ne stanno facendo altri c'è a
londra un bellissimo museo che è dentro
nella sua pancia un deposito dove tutti
possono entrare e che cosa significa
poter entrare in questi luoghi significa
poter liberamente accedere a delle
collezioni e scegliere i propri percorsi
individuali
accanto ai percorsi organizzati dai
curatori che ti mettono in ordine un
percorso di mostra eccetera tu prendi
coi detto e curiosità le segui i tuoi
interessi le tue domande e invece di
seguire un qualcosa di più ordinato ad
altri ti scegli il tuo percorso ti fai
il tuo museo vedete questa è una
fotografia è un artista che è entrato
nei depositi del museo di castelvecchio
e ha documentato fatto creato un'opera
d'arte dei depositi perfino quindi che è
fonte di ispirazione
guardate qui un esempio che mi ha molto
affascinato a berlino nel museo di
storia naturale dentro museo storico
antichissimo un po tipo il nostro c'è
una grande arca di noè tutta di vetro
vedete questa col contiene milione di
animali in alcool e questa è
un'apparizione quando torrini dalle sale
dove c'è un allestimento organizzato ti
trovi vanti questo tu puoi vedere tutto
e quindi questa è un po una scommessa
diciamo che in questa parte il pubblico
che siete voi a una parte molto attiva
perché siete voi che vedete che andate
guardate e potete scegliere e quindi
tutto questo a una parte importantissima
voi siete parte attiva di questo
processo di questa rivoluzione che penso
che sconvolgerà anche cambierà
radicalmente la funzione dei musei nei
propri siriani e quindi la mia è una
anche una così un augurio di poter
andare perché voi date valore alle opere
le opere se non sono guardate non
servono non non parlano così come i
reperti naturali se non sono studiati
restano muti non danno dati e quindi
adesso vediamo un po a me perché in
fondo quello che mi ha portato qui che
cos'è c'è sempre una ispirazione la mia
storia stata un po particolare e sono
sempre seguito le mie passioni ho avuto
questa fortuna da ragazza una delle mie
prime passioni è stata la canoa questa
sono io a nel 1985 ad ausburg ai
campionati del mondo
quindi è sceso i fiumi di mezzo mondo mi
sono allenata ho fatto vi sono cavata
tutte le le soddisfazioni forse l'unica
che mi è mancata è quella di fare le
olimpiadi perché ancora non c'erano
quando gareggiavo io ma la seconda e poi
è questa qui sono più vicina qua era il
castello sforzesco un castello un po più
grande di quello che che vedo oggi tutti
i giorni ma il senso delle due passioni
senso comune qual è la storia dell'arte
è lo sport che cosa mi hanno insegnato
il fiume mi ha insegnato la bellezza
della natura ma anche il rispetto della
natura e l'agonismo mi ha insegnato a
confrontarmi con gli altri a studiare un
percorso ad analizzarlo mi ha segnato la
fatica la disciplina le regole e anche a
sentirmi parte di una squadra come
adesso devo dire con orgoglio che che ho
continuato a sentirmi in questi anni e
quindi quello che mi piacerebbe che voi
vi portate
a casa un po dalla mia personale
testimonianza è questo che si può
tra gli infiniti percorsi dell
ispirazione creativa ci può essere anche
quello di lavorare per il pubblico per
il servizio pubblico che è un bene
importantissimo e che e questo mi fa
venire in mente un episodio di quando
era bambina un ricordo mio padre che mi
diceva sempre francesca pensa sia da
grande tu facessi il consigliere
comunale e io dicevo ma chissà cosa sarà
il consigliere comunale sicuramente uno
dei buoni consigli avevo sei anni per
cui era molto strana questa cosa per me
ma è lui che aveva questa fiducia è
veramente smisurata verso l'istituzione
pubblica mi ha trasmesso forse qualcosa
che mi ha condizionata mi ha trasmesso
qualcosa che poi ha fatto una scintilla
con le mie passioni e quindi vi lascio
con una suggestione che è ancora una
volta mi fa tornare su uno dei luoghi
più amati di verona che è la casa di
giulietta la casa di giulietta se ci
pensate è il frutto dell'ispirazione
creativa di colui che l'ha ideata e
progettata tra il 1938 e il 1940 antonio
avena il direttore dei musei civici di
allora e che ne ha fatto un museo sulla
passione e un museo sull'amore che vince
tutto grazie infinite
[Applauso]